sur
[Musique]
vous dans une vieille ruelle tout près
de la citadelle
d'ajacio dans la nuit toujours si belle
on entend des ritournelles des
bravos des touristes emballades écoute
les sérénades du
pays et plus rien d'importance quand une
ancienne romance vous
[Musique]
séduit au son des guitares viennent
filles et
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
garçons et chacun il chante sa
chanson
le temps passe comme un rêve tour à tour
chacun se lève pour
chanter et l'on chanterait encore s'il
ne fallait à l'aurore
s'arrêter mais les cœurs de tous les
cors battent avec plus de force de
chaleur quand s'élève la jaxienne que
pour finir il reprennent tout en
[Musique]
cœur
a au son des guitares viennent filles et
garçons
[Musique]
a et chacun y chante sa
chanson si Napoléon revenait près de sa
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
maison lui aussi chanterait sa chanson
l'enfant prodigue de la
gloire
Napoléon
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
na